quoi
bonjour voila je suis à la recherche d'
antoine breton je me demandais si vous
n'étiez pas à finir je suis blatrie
sokolovski
[Musique]
c'est toi
entre tu dois te demander ce que je fous
là un whisky tu as quel âge maintenant
40 levons aulas s'est toujours fait un
petit peu plus que ton âge remarquable
où
qu'est ce que tu fais maintenant savoir
si sérieuse je suis sage femme
ça va être merveilleux de voir naître
tous ces bébés au système phénomène avec
des frites et un verre de vin rouge tout
comme dans perthois banide d'alcool lors
qu'il est devenu
il est mort peu de temps après votre
départ
qu'est-ce que tu ferais si quelqu'un du
passé revenez vers toi quelqu'un qui t'a
fait du mal je change de trottoir pour
toi donc soyez vous étiez une princesse
hongroise que vous avez du sang russe
j'ai toujours aimé raconter n'importe
quoi et j'avais encore plus quand on ne
croit
ça va pourquoi tu fais tout le temps la
gueule dispard ac pendant plus de trente
ans et font jeu sont en garde à vous
parce que vous avez besoin noir que
s'accordent bien le gars avec ton père
mais bon bah à l'imaginer qui peut durer
à cause de moi ça vous flatte un abri
anti secte est belle quand tu t'en
canaille
mais c'est un père c'est pas possible il
faut que tu en match c'est un bon tu
vois pensez là
on a fait une belle que ces deux
bonjour la terreur alors ici j'aime ce
soir
pour vous demander pourquoi vous avez
disparu du jour au lendemain
non mais c'est pas possible un ton un
père oui je sais tu me l'a déjà dit
[Musique]